guys also we're producing other stuff
and you have other what else is coming
up for you guys in terms of war party uh
we have a script called graves that
we're very excited about which is
basically Serpico and poltergeist where
the cop car is the haunted house or just
kind of cool yeah this ain't called
pound-for-pound which is kind of an MMA
rocky type thing thorne which we're
gonna I can't tell you who's attached to
a very favorite woman but uh be split up
but it's but it's um I wrote that I'm
pretty excited about that we're gonna do
listen you know and we're just trying to
slowly kind of plod forward and do our
stupid little [ __ ] and we're not really
in the we're not really in the you know
over twenty million dollar it's not
although they're trying to drag us into
that yeah
our mission statement was not to make
movies over twenty million bucks and and
when you go and sit down with the
studios which Joe and I often have to go
and sit with studio heads or you know
the streaming companies and well you
know and you were like well you know we
look we have this thing for 15 million
bucks me what do you have for thirty
five million yeah like I mean we just
argent company Frank say they want to
make moves between 30 and 80 million
bucks my why no why I don't know they
don't want to pay us but they don't make
the movie Brad Pitt they want to give
him 20 I would pay if I'm not mistaken
there was talk about doing another thing
of wheel man or wheel man yeah wheel man
was our first movie together that we as
a company right we made it for five
million bucks and we did an early
screening of that at our Clyde Sherman
Oaks yes very very thankful we had
that's a good little movie that's a
movie there's a testament to nineteen
days and Joe nurtured this young writer
not so young actually and and gave him
notes and after a month this script he
gave me the script I'm like this is
amazing
we can do this for five million bucks we
gave it to CAA they took at the can the
next day to sell it internationally to
raise the money and Netflix swooped in
and bought the script
and they made this kid who directed the
movie
Jeremy rush he got signed by CAA and now
he gets movie offers that from the
studios from that movie because I never
give up
well yep I could be wrong about this but
I thought there was talk about doing
like another real man or am I wrong
about this no we we want you know we
wanted to but it's Jeremy we can't get
him off his butt yeah guys if you know
Jeremy rush hopefully I'm gonna stay
right in the camera I'm saying this
because it's gonna be a kleiner Jeremy
come on make will mention do wheelman -
yeah no you know he's listened he's a
very but he was a PA you guys know what
the kind of PA is right production says
and he was basically you know
shepherding actors from their trailers
to the set and he's been writing this
script for like years and he sent it
sent he was friends with Chris Pine and
Joe's friends with Chris Pine and sent
him the script on a cold call and Joe
read it and gave him notes and that
happened for like a month and we went
and made his movie within two months
this was a guy knocking on actor's doors
and now he is a director at CAA you made
a great movie by the way that when I
look at that film I go that's that's
Jeremy's movie we I'm very proud listen
I would do that all day every day if I
could just make movies like that I would
do it all day every day that's what I
want to do I you know blue so guys if
you got a script Frank's gonna tape send
it to me and on his way on your way out
your script yeah be like the rest of my
family see like the rest of my family in
New York who somehow became screaming
artists all of them